you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
players from nine nations converge in
st. Louis as US chest champs dot-com
presents the second annual summer chess
classic hello and welcome back to the
2019 Summerfest classic as always we're
your hosts Caleb ben b and g em Jesse
crying it's day four here at the summer
chess classic in the first three days
have certainly had quite the excitement
to them hopefully you know around four
can live up to that reputation let's
just jump into the standings and see
what we've got going on here in Group A
GM Jeffrey Zhang and David Howell are
now tied for first place both of them
winning one of their earlier rounds
David Hale actually taking out Sam
Shanklin the number one seed and Jeffrey
Zhang taking out Liam Lee who is
actually I believe the number three seed
behind Gawain Jones the Gowen Jones
himself is on an even score with one and
a half along with Darius wits and of
course lammle and Sam Shanklin rounding
out the group and over in the B group
it's the story of one man if that man is
Circuit Ganguly who is on two and a half
out of three and had a decent chances to
win his third round game but couldn't
quite pull it out behind him is Grigory
Oberon who won his last round game
putting him just 1/2 point behind Syria
Sam Savion and Havana's kuboos Ian are
both on an even score with one and a
half and Daniel Freedman and Igor
Kovalenko are rounding out this group
and over in Group C there's been a
change since yesterday our turfs night
suns actually defeated Brandon Jacobson
who used to be leading the group but now
is tied for second with Al Shean barodia
body Dmitry Gordievsky and around huh
Cobian and rounding out this group is
Christian shahrullah and let's take a
quick look at the tournament format to
see what kind of time control these
players are playing there are three
groups of six player double round-robin
so everybody in each group will play
everybody else in the group a total of
two times the time control for the games
is 90 minutes for the first 40 moves
with 30 minutes added on for the
remainder of the game there is a 30
second increment from move one as well
as a 30 move draw rule in effects so no
drawers before move 30 unless by
repetition and the schedule for the
events there is basically one game a day
with one rest day in the middle there on
Sunday June 23rd you can join us for
coverage for all of them the players
start their games at 1:00 p.m. but our
broadcast will always start at 3:30 p.m.
two and a half hours after the action
starts be sure to join us on YouTube you
can shout along we'll be keeping an eye
on that if you have any questions for us
there any questions for the players as
we get some of them in here for an
interview we'd love to pass those along
you can join us on us chess champs calm
if you're interested in following the
games live and you can also join us on
Twitter using the hashtag summer chest
classic and with that let's just look at
the pairings for group a we see Liam Lee
and Sam Shanklin have already finished
their game and that ended peacefully I
believe that was an Italian and without
too much conflicts David Howell is
paired against his fellow countryman
Gawain Jones and Darius wits is playing
Jeffrey Zhang in our key matchup of the
day Jeffrey of course is a co-leader
with David Howell and he'll be looking
to take on Darius today see if you can
push ahead push ahead of the crowd and
we see those players on the camera there
as they are deep in their game already
so what do we think about this one
Jessie yeah it's been a really
interesting game and here's the position
that we have now and I definitely think
Darrow has as either so you could call
it a small or significant advantage now
he's at least managed to get something
out of the position in a position where
I felt I thought the Jeffrey was very
clever in the opening where he got this
position
and I'm pretty sure this was planned in
advance and this is unpleasant because
black is threatening to get a better
version of a normal Kings Indian if for
example d5 then probably black doesn't
even have to wait too long to play f5
himself and is ready to play knight c6
next so arguably c4 in this position is
maybe a little funny and that was I
think a very nice kind of trap because
this end game I would say in general is
totally playable for black and in some
ways I rather be black here and the idea
is that we're gonna try to dominate both
nights with f6 first dominating the f3
Knight and then soon c6 to dominate this
night and if we kill off both nights
then we're gonna claim that we're better
and we're gonna say well my King is
gonna sneak into c7 and it will be a
force in the position where as the White
King will not be so the way I understood
it is because white committed to c4 now
the Black Knights have a square on d4
and whereas the White Knights don't
actually have that counterpart on d5
because black hasn't committed to
pushing his pawn quite so far up the
board yet right and I think you could
say is that one way to talk about it is
to say that black has a structural
advantage with the better pawn structure
but white has time he has more
development and so in the next phase of
the game it's going to all be about him
white use that extra time to do
something had to do something to shake
up this structure and he does and let's
see how he does it alright so before
Bishop e6 now there's several moves that
black can do here I'm sure for example
that c6 is playable Bishop e2 97 castles
and here's the first move that I felt a
little funny about
but I understand the intention black
plays Knight h6 and his thought is that
when black plays see six what he's
worried about is some kind of a some
kind of sequence with C 592 Knight c4
and then landing on d6 and it's not that
scary in itself but the knight on f3
does need to recycle himself out of that
terrible f3 square where again it's
dominated by these two pawns so the
knight is headed to f7 to talk to d6
right and maybe just a little premature
so like another option for black here
would have been to just do what you're
gonna do which is c6 and King c7 and
then talk about the rest of it right
seeing where the rest of the pieces go
anyways here we go 96 now rook e1 this
is clever because the problem is is if
you push c5 too early then we're gonna
get broken up with a fine right so
rookie 1 is just gonna allow me to be
able to play a three in response to a
five and after c6 we're gonna see this
in the game black has to worry about b5
and then an opening on the B file now
generally my intuition was it still
should be okay for black but let's look
what happened 9 f7 rook d 1c 692 and
here I want to play King c7 and this is
maybe where the the move is kind of
funny
Geoffrey plays rook e8 and I believe the
intention is to play Bishop f8 it's true
the bishop on g7 isn't the greatest
piece right so we're gonna play rook e8
and then Bishop Fe
however this gives white the time to
come up with a plan that I believe he
didn't see coming which was Knight b3
now
and now there's grief of the night
landing on a five and then after b5
helping land on b7 this is an
interesting idea I am not so familiar
with this idea of white playing b5 in
the structure but I guess that's that's
a pretty common idea for about to take
take a look at them alright well right
and you one way to talk about it is just
to say you know if white does nothing if
Y does nothing black will be better
right so you have your job is to create
drama your dramas great drama and you
know even even there's all kinds of
tactics - that are gonna come into play
with Knight d5 for example trying to
being the bishop but tonight up
unfortunately at the moment doesn't do
anything however it'll help us
understand why black chose this strange
move which is already a sign that things
have gone a little bit wrong because the
whole point of the opening is to hang
out on c7 connect the rooks and make
this broad claim that my king is better
than this guy right okay but now white
says okay let's do it
c5 and here we have to say of course
white is now better but we've the
structures dramatically changed and it's
our knight who has the chance of coming
in and and that's very difficult to see
how black can imagine getting his Knight
to d5 I definitely agree with that it
feels wrong to play c5 was there really
no no other choice for black Harry
already gone we got a bit astray
I'm sure he thought about other things
well the the the challenge is there's a
threat of takes in Knight a5 and then
right then you got to have something
planned against that yeah it's it's
heartbreaking to play c5 by the top you
know one thing that's interesting I was
talking to Sam Shanklin just just before
we came on air and he said this funny
thing where he said there's no way
Geoffrey's going to lose this position
like yes he is worse but he
can't beat him when it comes to what he
called a grind you can call this is rind
here because White's gonna have to still
outplay black right and I think when you
play c5 is black you understand that
you're in for punishment but if you have
confidence in your defending skills you
know then you can go ahead and play z5
you know it's clear you're worse but
yeah it's not even close to over right
so white has a variety of moves he chose
a for the bishop came as predicted and
now daro is thinking about it and we're
gonna head to time pressure
big-time be here because we're only at
move 16 and both players are gonna have
big decisions to make about where they
want to put the pieces for example when
does white want to drop Nike fine mm
what are we gonna do with the knight on
v3 these are all questions that White's
gonna have to answer and black is gonna
have to dance with whatever he chooses
yeah do we ever see Bishop takes d5
after Knight takes or 95 sure you can
definitely consider it you're gonna be
worse but you know that's gonna be one
of your options it just looks like with
the knight on f7 it's natural to try to
blockade if you know Knight takes d5
Bishop takes d5 if a pawn were to
recapture on d5 it's very natural to put
the knight on d6 and maybe find some
counter play against one of the
backwards pawns that way I think I mean
what we'll probably intend to take back
with the rook yes I think what the drama
for white is you stick it in there and
black doesn't have to respond instantly
and I think probably 96 is gonna come
almost no matter what yeah putting
pressure on the two weak spots in kind
of the white structure makes a lot of
sense and and let's say you know one way
to talk about it is to say that the
drama for black now is mostly to do with
the king
the king is finding it hard to come up
and connect the rooks and if the rooks
aren't connected then obviously that
guy's obviously out of play right so
yeah definitely an advantage for daro
he's gonna have time pressure and just
for the fans out there when you get this
low on time both sides are gonna make
mistakes that's a given I don't care if
you're Kasparov or whatever you're gonna
make mistakes in this next face so it's
gonna be a knife fight coming up here
well that'll be interesting to keep an
eye on but only 16 moves played in this
game so far right that's pretty pretty
insane by the way of when people talk to
me about how end games aren't
interesting I just want it I get angry
because this is beautiful this is good
chess here well this is almost not an
endgame right it's a queenless middle
game you might know it's gonna yeah you
different version is how you define
endgame fair enough so I want to say
Sam's game with Lesley M was a draw we
might talk about that later but let's
leave that for a bit why don't we take a
look at the B group let's look at our
yeah that's and so we have Sri Ganguly
the tournament leader playing against
Daniel Friedman today Egor Kovalenko is
off against the tournament number two in
the beaker Cori Oberon and we have GU
boozing playing against Sam seven so
this is our key matchup for the day
could be using of course squaring off
against the American youngster who I
believe is the number one seed and so
why don't we see what's going on in that
game it's like white has a nice night on
b6 by the way we had our picture wrong
that wasn't good yeah let's get GU Lee
buddy wait he is playing GU Busey and so
don't get confused and Sam I think
definitely has let's let's say he's got
a small advantage here because the
bishop is not great and this pawn is
little weak and this Knight which is
very proud probably can be neutralized
if nothing else by trading the Queens
and bringing the King to e7 is it enough
I don't I probably not it's probably not
enough but with the game is definitely
gonna go on and we're also they're gonna
make time pressure time control use much
more easily than the last game right you
remove 34 but let me just show this game
because it's really interesting you
would almost expect from that pun
structure that it was the King's Indian
but well it does turn into a King's
Indian structure for sure
go Busey and played a three and it's
kind of interesting I don't know if it I
don't know if a psychological but Sam
has experimented himself in strange
English openings so this was a attempt
to do in a strange English opening
there's this is I think portion oi was
one of the first to play this it's
totally playable let's look at what
happened why can't black can do a myriad
of different things he chooses this and
this strange movement I don't like it
but it's black is gonna be fine but
let's just say this after a three your
challenge is black is where are you
gonna put the dark square bishop and so
Sam decides on this where the bishop is
trying to get in d5 but is it really
pleasantly placed on c7 i I feel a
little funny about a little awkward okay
so in order to stop c5 go Busey and
makes let's call it a positional
sacrifice he gives up his dark square
Bishop and that's gonna set the tone for
the next bit where the question is can
this unopposed Bishop become a monster
or not at the moment it doesn't seem
that special but let's take a look
g3 Bishop t2 by the way is this v6 move
was a little weird
and because now on the next move sound
plays Queen b8 and so you'd figure if
you're gonna play Queen d8 just play it
now and make white wonder if you're
gonna play d5 or not but okay let's look
d6 castles Queen da b4
a six a six is clever in a lot of ways
one of them is that we might want to
bring the bishop if it gives us that
opportunity to come to to do a peekaboo
6 to do peekaboo on v6 so we v3d 497 and
now the committal move which is going to
take us into a Kings Indian structure I
felt that after this black was a little
bit better and I guess if I was white I
would have wanted to at least that would
have been my intuition maybe there's
something wrong with it but that would
have been my intuition because after d5
what we've done is we've entered this
position it's like a Kings Indian where
normally your Bishop is bad on g7 now
it's not it's kind of like ready to come
out and do stuff plus you got rid of the
white when I say hue I mean white got
rid of the dark square bishop which is
generally like your hope that you're
hoping against a Kings Indian to do
damage because your pawns probably gonna
end up on light square so you want a
dark square bishop and that means also
that this guy is gonna look particularly
sad so here we go
if we go back a couple moves yeah I
would have considered taking on e5
before anything else kind of because I
want to move my knight off of f3 it's
kind of open up that bishop on the
diagonal
but yeah d5 looks really weird to me cuz
knowing you have to take back with the
pawn it's just kind of admitting that
your bishop is going to be bad is there
any reason you might shy away from
taking any fibers yeah in general you
don't want to take on e5 okay for a
simple reason that this pawn is better
than that one and you're giving this
bishop more more more space well then
yet maybe even something like III the
point I just want to know my name 83 I
don't even play knight on f3 out of the
way so my bishop can start playing and
putting pressure fine I'm pretty sure he
whether it works or not he was probably
worried about be fine that maybe it
doesn't work but I think
so he was worried yeah something like
that but yeah anyways this was the
controversial move and what we have now
is a Kings Indian and the bummer is
simply that it looks like black is
faster and that the bishop on g2 is not
so hot so a4 and here here was a big
moment for Sam because he parts now
deliberately with his Bishop on v6 he's
gonna in a way you could say he's gonna
sacrifice the bishop for some time
clearly this would be an amazing piece
on the attack right with f4 at some
later date so giving it up I feel is a
big deal
white is threatening to play a five not
only to gain space but to shut down that
Bishop so you could have imagined other
things like an eventual even if he does
play a five to play rook c8 and this or
even b6 to tickle the a5 pawn but Sam
keeps it simple let's call it that
Bishop B 694 and Knight f6 allowing him
to take and claiming that he has the
initiative and it's true it's true he
has the initiative it's kind of
difficult like you you you want to play
Knight f4 a4 but the pawn on e2 is he so
then you compromise your position with
f3 and then try this business I don't
know 97 simple and strong simple and
strong and this position seems it seems
real nice to me you can do what what Sam
did in the game Queen e7 I'm probably it
feels like rook c8 as a candidate move
f4 as a candidate move anyways this made
a lot of sense now you for
and I kind of want I did want to play f4
before black but before white got that
right that would have been where am I
here on this position of course the the
drawback with that move is that after
Knight b6 your rook is not nearly as
cool as it's gonna be in this position
hmm right but okay I think a lot of
Kings Indian players simply say to
themselves I've got the better Bishop
I've got the weakness on e4 and I should
be a little bit better yeah and then
item b6 not so special so there should
be two forcing this off and white says
I'm gonna force everything off check to
the misérable King Queen g6 okay so here
we're gonna go and you know the King's
Indian is just a mean opening and here
you see that the pressure even though
the rooks are off the pressure against
the White King is simply going to
continue and the bishop on g2 is going
to continue to be poor whites hope
though could be to say that really you
only have one weakness which is the pawn
on e4 but black is also going to claim
that his Kings better with going to h7
eventually I assume so then they repeat
it a little bit will they take a draw
Sam shouldn't take a draw but he's got
he does want to repeat because he's down
in time looking at the board I think
they've already not repeated I think
black played Queen e8 at some point
oh he just in fact just played think
sometimes I don't I don't click on it
right so Queen f7 Queen f2 Queen e8
right and then Queen c2 from late
so yeah Sam definitely has a small edge
but it's very tough to win these
positions well yeah I mean there's some
immediate threats
I guess Queen c2 on Queen b5 you're just
going to play Queen to c4 it's difficult
to see yeah what what Black's idea is
going to be
I mean he's he's dreaming about letting
it all hang out with King age 7 and
allowing the Queen in and that's one of
the things he's got to try to calculate
and I you know one of the things I was
getting nervous in these positions today
because I came out is you know you say
Queen f7 Queen f2 and then you're like
oh no is that actually yeah I would
that's Beth probably just my problem
let's go to looking back and we'll go to
the secrecy group yeah and so let's see
what our pairings look like we have
archers Naik sons playing aids Christian
Charla Aramco Cobian plans
Brandon Jacobson and Alshon morontia
body plans Daniel and Gordievsky our
Dmitri I'm sorry and we're actually know
take a look at the tournament leader in
Group C Arturo's game against Christian
shrila and see what's going on there
yeah and we'll get to we'll get the edge
on this game too
okay so the count has had the count
who's known mr. Christian trill has had
kind of a difficult game and so he has
been struggling and I just want to say
like saans we were covering his game
with Jacobson yesterday and Jacobson
brutal loss yesterday like he got the
terrible position we left the air on air
he had a worse position and then he
actually lost the famous bishop and rook
versus rook yesterday I think he was
defending it and pretty well up until a
certain point then just one one misstep
is all it takes
really rough so anyways that's how it
makes sense is leading the tournament
here he's played a beautiful game and
it's complicated in this position but I
think we should can say that black's
pieces are hokey and there are a lot of
squares that are loose in blacks
position and the black king is worse so
let's maybe take a look at how it
happened alright so we got this position
and Christian doesn't want to play the
maracas see bind structure with cd4 so
does this and this is controversial for
a variety of reasons D 5 being the big
one I think white is just a little bit
better after D 5 to understand what
happens next we show a different
variation which goes like this
takes takes Queen C 5 and here what
white does usually is does not play
Knight c3 until black blocks it off with
Knight f6 the way by it I mean the
bishop so that you don't want to get
these pawns double at the end of the
world if you get your pawns double no
but it's just nice to play Bishop e2 and
I don't know let's say d6 then we'll
castle you know we're just waiting for
Knight f6 to happen so what Christian
gets really when make sense decides to
take is he gets that position with
arguably a tempo up because the bishop
is landed here probably not that big of
a shift okay but I guess I would say a
small improvement from the other
position because there's not clear that
the bishop wants to be on d2 right okay
so we get this and normal a normal move
here would be to play d6 and have a
dragon structure I would say it's
roughly equal oh oh we we lost the board
he lost the second a second thing we
lost the board for half saying okay well
we get that back up we see the players
actually on the screen here and so we
can follow live with what is actually
happening looks like white actually has
some pressure on the V file in the curve
he has pressure and he has space they
had a dreaded space but let's take when
we think about Christian defending this
position what he is saying is that yes
I'm worse but the d6 + e5 pawns are
meant to make the bishop on g3 bad so
it's like if you're a defender and you
can make at least one of White's pieces
bad you can at least have some hope that
you're not just getting totally
throttled unfortunately if you're
Christian is running down on time yeah
six and a half minutes left it's not a
lot for this type of position there's so
much still going on so many pieces left
on the board
the Christians got really unlucky with
the openings this tournament it's really
pretty hard from you know it's very
unpleasant because White has a lot of
different ideas with night age - with h4
with Bishop d3 to e4 or Bishop d3 then
you got to worry about weird Bishop g6
stuff so it's just a house of horrors
that this you know and notice that you
it's very difficult for black to even do
anything okay let's go through this east
six controversial b6 okay Bishop f4 and
98 and I thought that was a bad sign
that a third that 98 had that the push
backwards begins an e5 probably a good
decision
No the draw back to e5 this is going to
allow black to free himself a little bit
with f6 but when we look at this
position we'd like to take back with a
knight right but you cannot because of
our friend Bishop d6 so Queen f6 happens
and now it's interesting to think about
the further course the game because at
this
White's best piece I think we can say is
the bishop on g3 it's a beautiful
defender of the king and it's cutting
all of these squares and makes you
wonder about Bishop h4 right well let's
look at what Christian does is the
defensive strategy first he defends the
pawn then he says all right I'm going to
take some dark squares but take some
more takes all the dark squares and then
we're gonna take them all so you can see
that he knows he's worse and now I
believe b4 has been playing before in
there King h8 he knows he's worse but at
least that Bishop on g3 is poor and
there is a variety of moves for white to
play and a variety of ways to try to
improve the bishop
I mentioned h4 is an idea even the very
slow night h2 f3 and recycling that's
also an idea so white is for choice and
what our tour tonight sounds really at
once now probably you know is to find a
forcing continuation where he's
improving his play and and black you
know 17 moves to make with 5 minutes
something were you where you can't make
just simple intuitive moves right and
honestly are you that yes it's almost
hard to find a simple intuitive
continuations here right with you know
either side I think it's a lot of oh
well no whites white could play Knight
eh - I'm fine h4 I'm sure that's fine he
could even think about Knight c3 and as
I mentioned Bishop d3 d4 that looks
great - yeah I just meant that uh no
matter what white does it seems like
blacks gonna have yeah you know no no
easy responses here no only a difficult
position for for Christian and archers
nice ons if he wins this game that would
be huge for the for the C group as he
would go from trailing Brandon Jacobson
at the beginning of yesterday - well I
guess full points ahead if he were to
win today and
other games ended peacefully that's
right so any other games you want to
check up on I just want to say I was
hanging out with Brandon you know and
the kids lived a perfect life and he was
really upset and he was like I got to
get this anger out of me so we were
playing some bug house and I told him
listen Brandon look I've got a lifetime
of disappointment behind me and you have
just one game okay yeah let's look at
our what what what is our featured
matchup which is the LCM game and let me
say with else on it you know I've played
outshine a number of times and I've done
very poorly and one of the things I've
noticed he's he does is he really when
he prepares against you he is gonna look
to try to find something first where
he's going to know the position better
and it's gonna be a little squiggly but
squiggly I mean he likes it when there's
some weird dynamics in the position
where he feels like maybe you don't get
and this was an interesting attempt in
that vein which was he never born I
wouldn't say never but else I'm very
rarely plays e4 and this was clearly on
the assumption that he was gonna get the
position he got I was upstairs watching
this game and he had blitzed out all of
these moves way into the deep theory
here and black was the one who started
thinking around here with 97 but the
weird thing about this is if black is
familiar with this kind of structure no
amount of preparation is gonna get you a
real feel of it and red and kind of the
key is like how good is this unopposed
dark square bishop white wants to ghost
him and by ghost him I mean just let him
hang out and say he's not controlling
any important squares maybe they say
we're gonna gas like the bishop yeah
I've never said that before he's a
Gaslight the bishop so we got Knight cb4
a5 Queen b7 and black I feel just placed
this intuitively
and at least from what I saw I didn't
feel like white had any
special here I think if you play this
opening this is kind of what you're
looking for this kind of business
mm-hm so you know simple play but put
the pawns on the opposite color of your
unopposed bishop the bishop on g5 right
and here's our critical moment I guess
black doesn't have to play before but
now he this is the moment where he's
really gonna go for it so let's see what
he's up to snip snip snip here and he's
obviously going for the big the big
business the big business Queen a3 if he
wants to bail out I'm sure Queen takes
a3 is a draw he says no thank you
I want it all and notice that while he
thought about that he used all of his
time right and you know if you're black
if you're white you got a worried black
I mean you got to worry about Queen e5
but the simple thought is well I'm
attacking your bishop and so that's good
enough for me el Shawn says this that's
a spicy move that maybe Gordievsky even
missed maybe this is this looks like a
draw offer to me right because if black
does take the rook then white is just
gonna give it perpetual unless there's
some deeper idea but well it also looks
like else Shawn knows he's that already
asked he's played a great move yes
not okay first we get a snip on d2 and
now Gordievsky can I think he has a
number of interesting moves he can think
about here
well we can't think for too long and
that's always the problem well he knows
that do he knows that he can take the
dry instantly yeah so he's gonna let it
Leah let's watch this for a second he
knows that he can dip it down really
deep this is decision time and okay
so unfortunately it's very hard for
black to just simply improve the
position but and he can think about h5
but the problem is like even h5 in let's
say we just move the rook back or
something do we really have anything
well you can repeat the threat with rook
a to write something like that he's what
he's looking for it would be nice if
gotta be nice if we could defend this
guy but I really see no way of defending
that guy
my feeling with situations like these is
it's so nice for black to have the draw
in his pocket kind of and but then
players seem to kind of use that as an
excuse to use all of their time and then
as they get lower and lower on time it's
almost like well now I can't play on
because I have no time and I you know I
might mess something up and so we
actually do see a different move now
Bishop takes d5 is on the board okay
let's look at that so Bishop d5 and this
seems to force rook d5 and I suppose
rook a 2 is the question of the day
right what to do so you can see the
gardius he dropped down to 7 seconds
doing that Wow and by the way I have the
rook on a 2 but they have not he has not
yet done it right correct so we're
watching it's dipping down he's good at
I really I think this is something you
know I grew up without this increment
stuff and these guys are very good at
letting it dip you got 9 8 7
oh he sniped takes d5 that's unfortunate
so he must have seen something he did
not like after this move let's just
imagine here so row K 2 is what is the
fear is it rookie 5 minutes some rookie
5 and then Ricky 8 and then I guess
there's queen f 8 you know unworthily 5
I'm also terrified of rook a 1 I don't
even
really well what's the what's the a well
you're gonna have to go bishop d1 I
can't play Bishop f1 oh you do that yeah
so he took and I guess or just take some
Queen takes it's weird if you're gonna
take the draw you should've done Bishop
d2 yeah this is pretty strange I would
rather be white now no no it's totally
it's totally still just a cuz Queen a1
and so you pick up a pond right here and
then and then they're gonna agree to a
draw
yeah I think they're just signing the
score sheets now so pretty exciting I
think what is else Shaun drawn all his
games right he's got four draws on the
day although he did have I think a
promising position yesterday but they
just went around let's look at our
genius our resident alright this is
Brandon Jacobsen Oh before we jump into
that oh go man breaking news
Ganguly has actually drawn his game
today over in the B group yeah he was of
course the tournament leader he was
playing in C Daniel Freedman and the
game has ended in a draw and Daniel
Freedman is playing some old-school just
equalized chess usually in a term like
this you get more than one guy like that
but Daniel Freedmen's definitely that
guy so it's very hard to press he's
playing openings he knows well and just
defending and I didn't see any chance
for Ganguly through that game
pathologist's but over to a boy genius
boy genius Brandon Jacobs I have no idea
what's happening that seems to be a
running theme so Jacobson so he this was
the first game actually I'll say Brandon
did not look like he did not win the
opening battle oh Cobian knew what was
going on and I thought Jacobsen got a
funny-looking position early and here we
see him he's down the exchange and he's
clearly hoping he's gonna survive well
yeah definitely a lot of weaknesses and
the
at Camp though it's gonna try to pick up
a couple pawns it looks like right and
he's making a claim that this night is
at least needs some work and the bishop
might owe us a tempo when we land on
either c5 or a five he's got no time
left about two minutes two minutes for
Brandon Jacobs and what am I saying
yeah that's an eternity for that kid
let's let me let's look back and see how
it happened so as I said it seemed to me
like Coco Guillen knew exactly how this
was gonna go down baby b6 was played
quickly but then here's where Brandon
started to think on Queen b3 rookie sim
it's a little unpleasant and this was
weird to me I mean the next two moves Y
can do a lot of things let's just say
you were just playing normal chess you'd
probably play III here Coco bian plays a
328 Queen c2 and he played it instantly
I wasn't there watching I was like well
did you know that queen d8 was gonna
come and then he just went BAM Wow and
it was weird as like well is the idea
that you think you want to play E for or
something I didn't quite get it
so c6 Bishop d3 and now g6 so it's it's
a compromise with g6 he doesn't want to
spend a tempo you know I guess it's been
a temple in order to castle but now
that's gonna invite this move and when
you're down in already he was a little
bit down in time so it's already pretty
good pressure Knight of 6 I was
expecting h5 but clearly after h5
there's gonna be suffering with Knight
g5 anyway right giving up giving up that
g5 sway
the night is so when black plays c6 the
knight on c3 is bad so we're gonna
recycle him and that's an interesting
move
obviously well night if for it looks
more natural
oh and now it's getting too complicated
for me Knight f3 so let's think about it
Jacobsen is saying no way I can't that's
a saying I can't deal with playing h5
myself so I'm gonna try to block it with
a piece and then this move is saying no
if you don't I'm gonna play 95 because
it anyone interesting so is this just a
sacrifice oh he's so Cobian was thinking
that if we play h5 let's say you know
even after black castles then there's h6
g5 so at night l3 were preparing for 95
and we're saying there's no h6 g5 and
that looks like an advantage not only
because a little initiative against the
king but the rook on a7 is is strong so
he fixes it 95 rook e8 and now haha it's
funny you know white definitely for
choice but this unopposed Bishop will is
a great defender it means that you can't
break through on the dark squares and
this is a very committal move with f4
and I like Brandon's instincts here
check this out c5
now I'm sure DC was also a thought but
it makes sense that you want to try to
end it and then BAM so in this position
we are technically down a pawn but the
the night especially all three minors
but especially this night and this
Bishop are gonna be beasts and the
question will be for white will be can
you get a rook on a meaningful
meaningful open file
not too many exist in the current
position so but but it's gonna be tough
to keep them all closed right like yeah
it's gonna be tough there's the C file
that and the D file are potentially
gonna be open mm-hmm so I think Jacobson
I like what he did defensively because
he was in trouble but I think he's I
think these are gonna get the work here
all right a simple first move would be
Bishop e2 there's probably others played
did I call it
let's see Bishop e2 right was played and
Bishop e6 no trade and we're also
claiming now that this Knight doesn't
have a backwards move Jacobsen can play
very fast yeah I heard him yesterday
playing bughouse with you yeah yeah yeah
it's like every game there is shouting
to you to play faster play fast yeah he
was my partner for awhile
the guy plays so fast here we got King F
to Bishop e5 on the board so black has
got his pawn back in that dark square
Bishop is a true animal
I'll just tell a quick story about
Brandon Jacobsen so we're playing and
just to because he was mad he lost he
was mad but in a kind of playful way
what he did he didn't do this in a mean
spirit but here's the play for what he
just we were playing bughouse and he
would just like read his phone for a
couple minutes and then start playing us
you know all right a lot of confidence
there should be five and a little
tricky definitely tricky so white needs
some good moves and we're gonna come
back to that game yeah let's let's check
in on the count for sure because it's
gone it's gone crazy oh man oh man oh
man do I know what's going on no all I
know is that Bishop on g3 is now out
let's look at what white did here so we
have b4 King h8 and oh this is
interesting white said you know what my
bishop on g3 a man's freedom Wow buddy
snip snip snap takes takes and that's
pretty beautiful and I assume the idea
is that on Knight d4 there's some kind
of business like either 95 or probably
95 because in you're threatening Knight
g6 and that was that way that might have
been what Christian missed it's like
actually remember we are saying black
way to so many different leaders right
yes so you can't calculate them all and
c5 is like if you can get if that can
work oh man deep trouble deep trouble so
II for was attempted 90 to 95 and the
basic intuition is that black is lost
here but let's check it out rook d4
all right now it's rough night six and
then I mean we're down one way you talk
we didn't talk about this we can say
white has the pawn and the compensation
right after Knight d6 yeah that's really
rough so that looks lost oh and let's
see we had some takes here
so he took on d6 and pawn takes that's
that's technically okay well we'll wish
the count the best but that looks only
good luck I wanted to mention the game
we haven't taken a look at today in a
group mmm
was between Gawain Jones and David Hal
David Hal is leading the tournament and
it looks like he has a very pleasant end
game here yeah you know this was funny
I think Dwayne Jones stopped thinking
for a while and there's this funny thing
you know I think now the back in the day
I just want to say back in the day when
you're playing in a tournament it was
acceptable for people to like talk and
now I feel like people are not even
allowed to talk at all you know anyway
so I was hanging out up there and
there's a little room where you can just
watch the games being played on a
monitor and go away and comes up to me
and he says not much to talk about today
and I was like oh wait a second I
thought I wasn't allowed to talk and you
know I I said something like there was
interesting games but I in that moment I
kind of felt like oh do you not see that
there's a little bit of danger because
at that time it felt like there's a
little bit of danger because let me just
say going so so these both these guys
both these guys do this amazing thing
where they will start thinking early on
like when they know like in this
position you know these are people that
have studied a lot of opening theory and
they kind of start thinking about it
like in a deep philosophical way
especially how old and you can tell he's
not bluffing he's actually like thinking
about what
is going to do and he comes up with this
this thing this variation that I guess
let's call it harmless with g3 c5 this
all makes sense to me and black could
have also cancelled but he takes and
says let's just vacuum it up right
vacuum it up and it'll probably be a
draw which I think it should have been
in this position Bishop e7 I didn't well
maybe I'm missing something but to me
Ruby eight just looks like complete
equality complete equality he he took
and played this I still think it's equal
Bishop f4 is some kind of clever
you know he's threatening Bishop c7
right so way now maybe he had something
better but he starts he starts messing
around a little bit now after a move
like rook e8 you can say well white is
if anybody White's a little bit better a
four very nice and now the question is
do you allow a5 a6 gooing says no but
now the pawn is gonna be a target so all
of a sudden this horror thing has
happened where howl is better Bishop d2
snip
and this is called an advantage now yeah
it's significant one I think I'm not
sure it's significant no the pond on a5
is is pretty far advanced the the I
guess the black rook isn't the best
place it could be on a - I would I would
say this if well okay let's just talk
about the general dynamics first the
black rook is placed in the best place
if it were on a seven and the white rook
were on a four I would say that's a huge
advantage is just lost so the drama for
white though in this position is
eventually if you want to make progress
your King has to go and tend to the a
five point unfortunately from here
you're gonna get black is going to get
counterplay once the King runs so the
general like drawing strategy for black
in this kind of position as I understand
it is when the King runs we snip pawn or
two and then we run back and sacrifice
our rook for the for the a pond and in
the meantime our King and our pawns have
done enough damage on the King side that
we can at least try for a draw so I
think that even the Hoka wade could be
upset with himself here that he's still
fully in the range of equality yeah you
can see the bummer right the white king
needs to run now
one strategy for white is that one of
these aiming for is is aiming to try to
create a situation where the white pawns
are somehow involve all to counter play
and then we run yeah but it's hard to
see how that's gonna happen here
right it's right you if you move the
rook my king is gonna come up but more
importantly once you move the King over
here you got it you've got to aim for
that square b6y or you're gonna lose a
pawn or two let's look let's look at
Jeffrey's game that game has made quite
quite some advancements
they still have not made time control
but notice Geoffrey's time I think has
gone up but is that true do I remember
that right he had less than six minutes
before he was closed anyway yeah there
is this time has gone down quite a bit
well right it's hard because White has
to find a convincing plan here
so let's look what he does he plays
Bishop b3 b6 a oh it's a stir disaster
did we lose it
a 596 oh but you don't have it we can
talk about it from here yeah we'll go
back and look at the position as we saw
it let my eyes oh yeah we got a big time
scramble on our hands goodness um so
apparently I'm to blame I'm pressing
buttons with my feet disaster but okay
so what's going on in the current
position I have no idea
oh and it looks like we do actually have
a result over in Christians game
Christian lost food I guess we've
predicted that he's having a rough time
it's tough so we're looking at this tell
me what you see over here I don't
understand what's happening well we got
the bishop versus the night I can count
those pieces this white pawn on d5 I
guess that's it's the story of the
position right at the white pawn can I
think the story actually is is the rooks
right is there always is rook a 7 gonna
hurt but I'll tell you what we're gonna
back step but let's just look at this
position here on the board for a second
so right wait Bishop f1 was just plain
and
how devastating is rook a seven and a B
I guess is the question I don't I don't
know if I I believe too much in it what
do you think well Geoffrey needs to find
a move let's yeah let's stay with this
I'll backtrack in a second we'll look at
some of the moves it can be six plays so
let's try to consider if let's just look
at the obvious so what happens after
root K seven I'm gonna guess that the
ideas would be one so that if you snip
I will snip this way to get rid of that
and that rook right
oh my god it ro has just seconds left
yeah you could check on a6 first that's
the other option I'm sure he's thinking
about and then play Brooke a7 okay
King c5 maybe maybe it's helping black
rook a7 we'll see if I'm there might be
something else besides rook e1 but I I
don't know what else it would be I think
with two seconds on the clock you played
that move yeah these guys are amazing
Jeffries you know Sam was right Geoffrey
is very hard to crack in these positions
rook e1 looks to me that looks
sufficient because I don't know what
we're supposed to do after it b1
mm okay timeout we can do check here
then if Kings know I know this is
nothing my rook is beautifully holding
this thing so right yeah it's difficult
to tell then you can check with the
other rook is there anything going on
there well then then we got to ask
well okay actually you're right Lou this
is a good question so king c5 and then
this check to the miserable King Oh
interesting yeah that looks pretty shady
right you have to go to b4 i guess in
this position but then rip b7 and let's
show that so if King d4 this is this is
terrible
it seems unfair that the bishop can
protect the Brooke but unfortunately
that's the rules of chess so things
aren't that strong king c5 would be
forced check to the miserable King and
then let's say King here now just to
point out 92 is the threat and here
white has both he has all kinds of
checks back here and he has a simple
waiting move at his disposal as well all
right well while this game continues I
think I'm actually going to step out of
the studio and we're going to get group
C leader archers and icons in front okay
great yeah so yeah we'll watch Jeffrey's
game here for a second and let's go I
want to go back for a second to see how
it happened so rotate one King b7r okay
for you can actually see the build up
right of the rooks now on the a file and
how it went down
it looks very nice for white here but it
got perhaps more messy then he wanted it
to be and here we have this situation
yeah I root b1 not played we're kind of
waiting on that now all right so I'm
joined here by arced ornate sons how do
I pronounce your name property I think
it pronounced in just fine Oh make sense
is the English person make sense is the
German version as long as you don't say
nonsense yeah I was commenting my game
somewhere at an online and he said
nonsense well beautiful game - nice
games in a row where should we start
no I mean I'm just playing my game
it's not like I'm planning ok today I'm
gonna have to win because I'm with bad
color because I'm playing every single
game against Jaco biana is also no plan
for the job it just happened that I had
to play for this drawing the end but I
just enjoyed the atmosphere here I mean
it's right yeah yeah very honored to be
here the squab time when I received the
official invitation to play here I mean
it was all my god I'm gonna play in Sao
Luis nice yeah yeah so yeah I just did
enjoy my time here and I try to let me
ask you about this decision I was I've
had similar things in the past in my
understanding was here that you see the
board ok you can see it up there too
with Queen b6 then you do like this
thing and then play like this we can go
a few moves back decided to play third
most c4 recently I brought the database
for modern chess I wrote all stuff all
kinds of stuff about and this is an
approach I did then I'm 10 either mass
cooperation Bishop e5 I did the rustle
emo we should be far as well
and yeah recently I brought about the
paulson and I was recommending this move
c-4 in my day the message was at least
about one month ago and the point is if
I play immediately d4 instead of C for
black has the possibility to reach to
the dragon right so that's the point
yeah it's like I don't mind I just try
to say stay true to my database I mean
what I'm recommending to my yeah okay
yeah c4 there are some nuances Bishop g7
d4 and if he takes on d4 so it's just a
natural mirage or a favorite absolute
favorite yeah and I think d6 is more
tricky here
so d6 and I cannot really take on the c5
because dita XD takes Queen takes Queen
King takes Knight c3 and the point is
Bishop c3b Tikes an Isis except I think
this is slightly risky for white
although a computer says it's about
equal sure sure so I would play probably
d5 fine here black has the opportunity
to either switch to some kind of a bank
of it b5 right or some kind of a benoni
6 but I'm not obliged to take on d5 for
the C pawn I mean I keep on this
position if you would arise so but okay
he didn't played he played instead of 6
96
yeah it's playable move I don't remember
exactly the analysis d5 was possible
here - oh yeah yeah but he would play 94
94 CT x and d 4 and 4 by 5 something
like that I thought that was better for
you
but what he did probably was a little
bit better - as long as I get my Rosa
Bonheur I'm very happy to see 5 ok good
right what I was saying was like in this
variation like what I felt was going on
was that he got me arguably a slightly
better version of this because you ended
up having your Bishop committed on D - I
didn't agree with you because I have the
pawns on c4 on e4 I mean this is space
advantage for me and easy to play and I
think the biggest problem for Christian
was that he was not exactly familiar
with this position I mean he's a very
good player right
and he played I think this kind of
structure for the first time so he was
pondering too much time try to figure
out what is the correct continuation
there and yeah so he got in the time
trouble I know yeah yeah what's the
thread and then I guess we're gonna say
e six was the first kind of strange move
B 6 is playable but I think he rushed
with it now usually this time a plan
here is D 6 D 6 Bishop e6 maybe a 6 B 5
I'm not sure but perhaps it was also
interesting if he would actually try
immediately like b6 Bishop decent
there's this idea that at some point if
I play with White Knight d5 only then he
plays east so I think he just gave me
nice cuts up the time gonna explore this
weakness on these six I think I got very
very good position of the opening yeah
you know it's funny I think a lot of it
is some people can't deal with the
Marathas he binds he doesn't so he tried
to shake it up real fast here yeah and
this before
actually yeah Bishop before yeah I was
thinking about maybe II 45 is a game
decider but I don't think it was it was
a 45 95 so yesterday because 94 Bishop
g5 is just killing the game almost so I
thought of many moves like I think it
was Hydra Bishop e3 OB for for example I
could play here Bishop e3 no he would
play he could not BEC on a3
he cast over e3 Queen c7 not b5 again
the only moves Queen b8
oh yeah yeah but I couldn't find exact
continuation here something like 95
Queenie 5 it's not like a win some
material here Bishop f3 is meant by d5
if I play Bishop d4 he plays something
like Queen g5 I can put the knife
through these six but I wasn't sure I
mean okay yeah yeah I just didn't look
like I should go for these positions so
already here you have an embarrassment
of riches
yeah you got more than one that works
I'm almost winning the game in sewers
all right I was I was thinking about the
quite a lot so [ __ ] before was my
second choice and
yeah he played 98 here if I've doesn't
work in am also a tree okay maybe it's
that the fader I could have played
something like I like what he did yes I
mean I was meeting at 5:00 with before
Queen e7 an e5 and it has a terrible
position right raise the point of a
three and he played correctly he play
Queenie seven and here realized I have
to play five otherwise he's gonna switch
to Hedgehog after D six uh-huh right and
yeah B should be seven was a smart move
because he is waiting for me to play
Queen d2 and he can try to trick me with
95 yes yeah patek code of threes of 94
Forks and b3 star a and the Queen d3 was
very accurate yes that was very proud of
it
sure and he played f6 I think that's a
mandatory there was a point 94 right
yeah to connect six he played with a
queen yeah I'm sure that's very accurate
but maybe it doesn't matter maybe he
should have tried to take the bishop so
that the night nyet can jump to g g7 f5
something I don't know but it's it's not
very pleasant position for him okay but
maybe it doesn't really matter so he
took Queen f6 yeah I'm the bishop g3 I
think it's just the Soviet advantage for
white he has a number of weaknesses
right right no I very unpleasant I was
expecting him to play something like we
know five tried to try to trade off the
Queen's uh-huh and I was not sure what
I'm gonna do am I gonna retreat Queen e3
something but I thought he'd made this
plan here did I tell you if you feel
like this is what he was thinking was he
said to himself I'm gonna try to make
this bishop bad I think he had this idea
to play 1979 to five summer but it
doesn't really work I mean play 97 if he
has to deal with the problem night of 3e
5 and that's the biggest price yeah so
he would need to include
d6 and then play 97 9 to 5 if he I think
that's the only viable plan here for for
black right
yeah he tried to make it work but they
did not so yeah what did that play Roxy
- ah here is a little point yeah
instead of Roxy - I was thinking about
94 unfortunately it doesn't really work
it is impossible because of Luke c2 on
black holes immediately uh-huh
Queen a5 unfortunately this works for
black and the point is not h4 supposedly
the black queen is trapped black place
95 so all of the tactics as far as I
calculated they work in blacks favor
unfortunately Wow yeah the hand Knight
is hanging on e force I could not really
do this so yeah I I decided just to play
some positional chess rook C - uh-huh
yeah I mean look Seto I just removed the
rook from c1 so that's just I'm just not
that for let's let's show that so in
this position when we go night at 593
night h6 now the bishop is hitting the
rook yeah oh man so it's funny of course
you're just watching the game it just
feels like a positional move but
actually you also have a g5 very quickly
uh-huh I did not go play too much
perhaps I could have went 84 but he has
some sort of funny tactics they're like
h4g for not H 295 I just didn't feel
like going for this position so yeah I
mean h5 is bad right
h5 is 94 95 you get this very nice
outpost on g5
yeah but 95 looked very um unclear to me
I cannot take any fur because queen of
talkin G to checkmate
so yeah I did not look exactly like fun
position to play so I just decided to
play it safe I played h3 just in case so
the time is this g4 threat nice and
simple
yeah really I was expecting him to play
d6 here and after d6 the point is he's
threatened to play 97 now because yep
again he couldn't play 97 because I'm
threatened 95 or yeah no he has got this
'if r-square covered although I don't
know maybe he still he doesn't have this
97 because of the 95 there yeah
but I would have a play something like
Queen c2 that was the original idea
mm-hmm and prepare something like maybe
even maybe even 94 some 94 yeah but it's
very very unpleasant for him and he did
not play that he played something else
could take Queen e7 Queen e7 I was quite
happy to see this move because now 97 95
is no longer immediate threat for me
here I I could not find the exact plan
so I decided to provoke some weaknesses
and I play Knight b5 although I was not
sure if I should allow him to play d7 d
5 because it's sort of relieves his
position but yet again it makes my life
so much simpler sure yeah
because I just take on d5 and here's a
lot of weaknesses I don't know if he
takes for the epon let's say d5 CTX he
takes I play something like I don't know
maybe night of 3 to d4 he has so many
weaknesses on f5 h5 right the bishop h5
is incoming so it felt very unpleasant
and if he takes for the rook so it just
I don't know retreat somewhere to Queen
e3 or something
sure yeah so I was provoking him to play
a 6 and then I would I would think about
either 96 or 93 and then after Queen e3
I can target opponent basics so that was
the best one I could come up and
actually here already anticipated that
he could play e5 if it fell for me sort
of like a desperation move
yeah it's very pleasant for him and it
was part of my goal to provoke him some
kind of weaknesses but yeah Queenie tree
already had learn to play beforehand so
Queenie trees I think it's very nice
move and here I was thinking he could
play 84 immediately but still it's worse
for him yeah so II for and apply 94 and
I think he has to double take on d4 I
don't know and then play 97 something so
this it takes I take with the rook and
97 but this isn't fun all right it's not
I mean I can play something like
we did or something maybe I don't know I
mean yeah it should be for his age five
Oh Bishop g4 is Indies okay I did not
see but you know you're gonna have
something in that position
do you have something yeah this is yeah
not farm so he tried to do his best
he played d6 and yeah I played before I
was very happy to find this move
initially I was thinking about ninety
three here instead of the b4 uh-huh
but after Knight c3 he plays Knight a5
and yet again there's this threat to
play Bishop of 394 there re aside years
the point 93 94 so I thought this is
quite a tricky position and the point
what I planting in the game v4 removes
this possibility for him to play Knight
a5 and also which is not least important
I threatened to play sefa right
and I think he completely missed this
because what he played King h8 actually
worked in my favor and after King h8 c5e
I I don't know but it feels like it's
crushing you know I felt you know when I
was looking at it I felt like there were
so many things you had to worry about
like even if you don't see this you got
to worry about h4 you know we're about
92 you got to worry about just simple
building moves like that it's like oh
there's so many things don't worry about
yeah I just need to make sure that I
don't miss any tactics so I thought
perhaps he instead of King JJ he could
have played like a six here mmm
six 93 and 94 well okay in the worst
case scenario I can just take 94 eat
eggs
Queenie seven Ruki seven and something
like Knight a for sure and if he plays
something like Knight of 6 f 3 at least
from afar I saw that I'm winning
something Knight a5 Bishop of - yeah
yeah yeah so he felt bad for him sure I
think he also calculated that I'll keep
liking h8 and somehow I immediately
thought that King h8 should be a mistake
because I already was threatened to play
C 5 and now various motives to take on
e5 work in my favor because the King on
h8 is badly position so I calculated
some
major lines I just did not go play too
much I mean c5 was like a natural choice
for me yeah I liked it a lot I admired
it because it's like this is the only
piece that's bad and it's gonna get
fixed the moment you get c5 in right so
it's like so he cannot really take with
the D pawn on c5 let's say beta X beta X
and he plays D tags because I just crush
with rudy' 8 a 95 yeah there's so many
threats Bishop c4 I mean forks on g6
move d7 I mean yeah it's very terrible I
mean so the whole plan for black
backfired he played this h2 the g5 and
he corrected himself these weaknesses so
I just exploit them so d 5 would be 5 I
saw that beforehand
25:55 initialize go quite a long in 94 I
saw a 4 but I was not overly concerned
and after 94 I would play
Luke e5 it felt like it's easily winning
you also have 95 - right that's what I
thought you were gonna do anyway oh ok
no I mean I did did saw this maneuver
but I did no combat I think I would just
play they both look pretty good I did
not spend too much time there so it felt
like it should be winning and here you
surprised maybe d4 and yeah that was
quite tricky and 92 I was expecting him
to play 94 before not be for yeah and at
least I think I calculated the win here
route these six if he thinks attack with
the C pawn on the other night is falling
so 9c - Queen b3 and e3
I was expecting something like this
right but it felt like it should be
meaning at home boss did not calculate
too much perhaps I'm even winning after
ethics and e3 so the point is if I take
Queen c2
he takes on f - right so there's some
crazy tactics king of funk we need to
know
no Queen eat oh sorry yeah oh this yeah
yes let's see okay great so beautiful
game you know you're leading the
tournament yeah it feels very nice I
mean obviously yeah so yeah I mean I
managed to link to games and white the
start was slow I was playing awesome in
the first round I got quite a good
opening opposition I think I was out of
the theory after some time I'm in five
because I was gonna play a 45 in the in
the morning yeah I'm gonna just got this
feeling okay I'm gonna play it English I
just saw the play c4 he surprised me
with their first moose and after the
game he confessed that he just changed
change his repertoire it's not in the
database right right yeah you 5gm
sometimes can be out of the book I mean
yeah it happens okay well good luck for
the rest of tournament thank you and
we'll hopefully have you back down here
that was a beautiful game and I think
we're gonna see more like all right yeah
all right everybody let's take a quick
look at what else is going on and I
guess our big questions we had a result
in Jeffrey's game and Jeffrey as Sam
Shanklin predicted was able to hang on
in this position where it looked very
dangerous for him and he did not play
with b1 we saw some conceivable grief in
that variation but it said played king
c5 saying that you can have the h7 poem
but it's not that big of a deal
snip-snip
just snip snip he's not worried about
anything apparently Bishop c4 and then
they agreed to a draw so you know when
you when you play this way and you play
c5 get ready to defend and he did it and
you know and you imagine making 2700 as
Jeffrey's doing it's not always the sexy
games that are going to lead you
but it's gonna be the ability to hold a
draw in a game like this and impress the
stuff from Jeffery and impressive stuff
from archers as well absolutely what
what a couple of games we had there so
what game striker right now as we head
into the latter half well so again
Ganguly drew as we said and I'm gonna
say Howell and Gawain are gonna draw
they're gonna do a friendly English draw
and let's look at Kovalenko some
surprising stuff happened there where
earlier I felt Kovalenko was better but
he is clearly not better anymore he's
got this difficult endgame it's clear
that something went wrong hmm White has
really no counter play against the black
King and the drama is simply gonna be
can black pick up one of these points
I'm gonna guess
yes that's my intuitive reaction is yeah
you should be able to pick up one of
these bots not sure what you do with
white here live in New York c2 is coming
and Brooks III all kinds of stuff is a
problem and rook f6 rook f2 there is a
bummer very difficult so we might come
back to that one just to see how it
happened but let's look at Samuels game
to see if he was able to squeeze
anything out of that position it's
looking like maybe not with no minor
pieces on the board down to the Queens
but uh Sam is up a pawn here he did
steal upon for his troubles
and I wouldn't say it's over yet not
over yet
no interesting thing I guess to ask is
if we go down to a pot endgame it's I
guess well it's probably a draw but
there's you know all black has to do is
put his King here and then he's allowed
to play b6 or be fine right so yeah
Sam's gonna get some time to think about
it well at least he's the only one that
can win it let's put it that way and
then there's just one game left in Group
C to keep an eye on it
and that's our friend the genius randoms
I was very interested to see how this
was gonna happen let's look at how it
went down so Bishop e2 is pretty much
where we left him Bishop e6 King F -
Bishop e5 obviously the b2 pawn is a
problem white says goodbye rook you know
I know that there are minions like to do
the exchange SEC but this is a little
bit you really want to do it or he did
it and now we have to ask like is white
even better because he has a problem
with the night on g3 being terrible well
I got some promise to write the d5 pawn
is always gonna be a little bit loose
can be targeted by the light the light
square Bishop well I mean it would be
amazing if black I mean just the black
yeah it's blacks in the game it's kind
of like I mean the the fact that I can't
answer immediately who's better it means
that black really caught a break
absolutely so Rick's e8e for okay I like
that move by the way that was a nice
thing I feel like a lot of times people
are obsessed about the isolated Queen
pawn but the thing to obsess about is
your bad night on g3 so maybe white they
get a little something-something
but it's not much is it
and it looks like he's holding all right
to me for the moment and it's bishop to
the nice square on d5 okay there's
there's maybe a little push all right I
still don't really believe it but
they're they have a they've made it
they're gonna take a break
they're gonna take a break and think
about it it looks just hitting that that
move forty in looks like Huckabee and
has actually been thinking for quite a
while here in this position
yeah the bummer is if you play b5 your
seat Pont is weak right and Brandon just
needs a couple moves really to start his
own play on the Kings side and maybe
white regrets pushing the king up to f5
because it's later on it's gonna be a
valuable piece up there yeah it looks
like a lot of the drama for today has
kind of been decided then oh no the
drama is still coming still coming this
drama is still coming yeah Brandon let's
say you know let me put it this way this
is the fateful thing that I see
happening in Brandon's life Brandon is a
genius kid and it's gonna obviously as a
genius in chess but also he's going to
Columbia so he's clearly like a wizard
of some kind the kid needs positive
reinforcement this summer if he's going
to be taking chess to the next level if
you know he just does okay my experience
with genius kids is they will they will
still play a little bit but they're not
going to go all in to go all in as say
for example Jeffrey's drawing has done
you know they need positive
reinforcement and it's it's it's a rough
it's a rough business that that's a life
choice that's on the line today mr. Howe
Kobe and if you want the kid to play
chess just let him win just let the
woman rest on your consciousness let's
go back the ending careers I want to see
how this happened with a Kovalenko so
this let's look at the opening we'll
breeze through this opening
I'm a boring person myself so I've done
this for white it is in fact not that
boring of a thing
and Mike's experience with this position
if black plays d4 is that we are we
being white or a little bit better for
precisely the reason that happened here
with 9a for you couldn't played Knight a
four before castles - but it's a similar
thing
snip-snip and here I felt like yeah
there's a variety of ways to play here
where the bishop combined with the Queen
side majority should give an advantage
g3 may be controversial you could then
the natural move let's say was oh the
natural move did not work the natural
move was c5 but unfortunately that
happened right so he played g3 the other
it's kind of a funny position the other
thing of course I'll say the other
natural move to consider was that that
looks I'd rather be white rather be
white I'm sure there's all kinds of
complications but I'd rather be white
their stellar Bishop so this went down
c5 and now there's a funny tactic if
Queens see fire then I can just take
because your rook is me and counter pins
counter dead that's right so we get this
business
so you notice he eventually did that
anyway another taking on D form playing
Bishop f3 so it feels almost like you
should just done it earlier yeah I'm
gonna like to see it with the pawn still
on c4 kind of keeping an eye on the d5
square for for a moment so black clearly
is making some counter play on the Kings
side before white crushes over there in
the Queen side that's a dubious to see
that's like I don't know buddy
so we can begin to sense how it went
downhill for white
I think gh is a move that you
you when you really really really want
to win of and are ready to take some big
risks
yeah does doesn't feel right doesn't
feel right we need to well that's simple
enough that's simple enough
yeah the night is an evil attacking
piece that's very simple to play there
rook g3 d3 now we gotta say black is
better yep the pieces that's where the
exchange fell and soon after I guess
pawn started falling yeah c6 and now
he's gonna he's gonna massage that pawn
out of existence here too so this is our
current position and yeah it looks lost
it looks lost and so we haven't you know
I'd love to have Oberon and he's he's
been playing these openings that have
been mostly non theoretical no and he
likes to play just it seems like just
sound positional chest a little bit of
tendency to go to the endgame and yeah
looks like he's gonna win this one all
right well why don't we take a look at
our standings for the day George let's
see where it looks like we're gonna end
up so over in a group Jeffrey Jean drew
his game
we are expecting David Howell and going
Jones to draw that endgame you know
David Howe is upon to the good it looks
like a drawn wreck ending right
Darius roots drew his game against
Jeffrey and Lili and Sam Shanklin of
course also drew their game so no
changes in the standings possibly at the
end of today but right over in the B
group Serena Ganguly has drawn his game
but that has left the door open for
Grigory Oberon to win his game which we
think he will and that will give us two
leaders in the B group for the first
time
Sam 7 is
playing against Igor Kabbalah or not
Kovalenko he's playing ants Kabu Xion
and we're expecting either a draw or
maybe Sam to possibly come out on top in
that game I think Sam's gonna massage
him for a long time all right I think so
high hopes for Sam
Daniel Friedman is the person who
managed to draw against Syria Ganguly
and I go of course Kovalenko is not
looking so good against Gregorio proned
right over in the C group archers night
Suns is the man of the day winning his
game and jumping out to three points
possibly a full point ahead of the rest
of the field
although Brandon Jacobson is going to
have to hold on for as long as he can
against our own poco bein to get his
half point yeah I like I don't think
Bren I I don't know what's going on in
the position so I think anything could
still all right and upcoming broadcasts
we have actually some exciting stuff
coming up coming ahead in the days
following the summer chess classic we
have the Croatia tournament the
corrosion Lake of the grand chest or all
of the regulars will be there the you
know I think the 12 is it now in the
tour will be playing in Croatia and
directly after Croatia we actually have
the US Junior Championships the u.s.
girls junior championships and for the
first time ever the u.s. Senior
Championships so some of those classic
faces you've seen maybe from growing up
in chess will be returning to chess
coming out of retirement maybe that's
alright in the senior changeup and I'm
gonna be there and you know I'm just
waiting the years down a couple more
years to go and I can play in that event
and the training is starting now alright
you have to be fifty to play you gotta
be hey I just got a couple more years to
go alright well thank you so much for
joining us here today on the broadcast
be sure to join us tomorrow at 3:30 p.m.
our usual time and quite an exciting
around a lot of exciting games this is
so far been a incredibly interesting
tournament a lot of weird chess unusual
chess being played and it's it's
to see any final thoughts Jesse players
are getting tired you really start
seeing a little bit more a little bit
more blood coming around it's gonna get
brutal for some people let's put it that
way all right we'll see you next day
next time this has been a presentation
of the st. Louis chess club
[Music]